[Música]
se cumplen tres meses del inicio de la
guerra en Ucrania Este es el conflicto
armado más grande que ha habido en
Europa desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial
terminada en 1945 y su impacto en la
población civil ha sido enorme Y es que
esta guerra ha provocado el
desplazamiento a gran escala más rápido
que ha habido en el viejo continente en
los últimos 70 años y ya ha dejado más
de 3.900 civiles muertos según la ONU en
lo militar Rusia Ha logrado controlar un
corredor en el este y en el sur
ucraniano que lo puede conectar hasta
moldavia especialmente a la región
prorrusa de transnistria mientras que
las tropas ucranianas han logrado
mantenerse en kiev la capital y
recuperaron harkis la segunda ciudad más
importante del país a continuación les
mostramos un resumen de qué ha pasado
militarmente en lo que va de la guerra
la guerra empieza el 24 de febrero con
una ofensiva rusa en el norte los
objetivos la capital kiev y harkif la
segunda ciudad del país en los primeros
días el crimen también se moviliza en el
sur junto del puerto de Marruecos donde
los rusos organizan un sitio después la
ciudad de gerson calle rápidamente sin
embargo en el oeste La contra ofensiva
ucraniana defender nikolaive e impide a
los rusos avanzar hacia odesa A mediados
de marzo y el siguiente la toma de la
urbe principal acaba siendo mucho más
difícil de lo que Moscú imaginaba y no
llega a concretarse puesto ucranianos
resisten en el norte con contra
ofensivas eficaces hasta retomar control
de las regiones alrededor de la capital
el 2 de abril Rusia se retira del Norte
del país y empieza a concentrar sus
esfuerzos en el sur y el este de Ucrania
Marriott sigue sufriendo bombardeos
intensos
caía en manos rusas en las últimas
semanas las contra ofensivas ucranianas
han alejado a las fuerzas rusas de
harkif pero en Marriott tras dos meses
de fieros resistencia ucraniana los
rusos finalmente logran controlar la
estratégica ciudad portuaria y la planta
metalúrgica dental los rusos ahora
concentran sus esfuerzos en el dumbas en
las regiones del lugar y duneski el
presidente ucraniano ha dicho este lunes
Que las próximas semanas serán difíciles
para su país qué tanto ha ganado Rusia
con la guerra en Ucrania Cómo se va a
reconfigurado la geopolítica occidente
tiene la suficiente fuerza para detener
las intenciones de Moscú o prevalecerán
los deseos del presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin le ha servido el conflicto a la
otan para revitalizarse Y por qué los
organismos internacionales han sido
insuficientes para frenar los combates
hoy en el debate de France 24 los tres
meses de la invasión rusa a Ucrania y
para analizar este tema saludamos a
Marcela del Barça directora de la
escuela de relaciones internacionales de
la Universidad Anáhuac Querétaro quien
está en Querétaro México también está
con nosotros Vladimir rubinski profesor
de ciencia política y relaciones
internacionales de la universidad y Ceci
él se encuentra en Cali Colombia yo soy
María Clara calle y estaré con ustedes
en reemplazo de mi colega Santiago López
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en el debate con todos
sus comentarios y preguntas lo pueden
hacer A través de todas nuestras redes
sociales estamos en Facebook Instagram y
Twitter y no se encuentran como arroba
france24-alpiso.es mi cuenta personal es
María Aguirre los leemos y les recuerdo
nuestra etiqueta numeral el debate f24
esperamos todos sus comentarios
comenzamos y para eso quiero darle la
bienvenida a nuestros invitados y
comenzar con una pregunta concreta para
Marcela y es el 24 de febrero cuando
Rusia comenzó lo que ellos llama una
operación militar dijeron que era para
desmilitarizar y desnasificar a Ucrania
concretamente el don Bass qué hay detrás
de esa afirmación Y si realmente hay uno
movimientos nazis detrás de esto
Pues creo que eso es un tema muy
controvertido a final de cuentas Pero lo
que sí siempre fue claro yo creo y y
hasta transparente era el tema de que lo
importante eran las regiones prorusas
del Don vas no como que de alguna manera
Rusia siempre fue Clara con el pretexto
no del nazismo Pero de alguna manera así
es el hecho de que existan estas estas
poblaciones prorusas y que
el tema de de de los acuerdos de minsky
y de las de las regiones digo que
autoproclamaron repúblicas y el tema de
la autonomía como que es él siempre fue
el ingrediente principal no entonces
creo que que de alguna manera hoy lo
estamos viendo reflejado después de que
la ofensiva pues este baja del Norte
hacia el sur y y y toma parte de de de
las dos salidas al mar que son
estratégicas e importantes
Hoy está concentrado ahí no O sea hoy
por hoy el día tres meses después donde
se va a intensificar y donde de hecho
este pues si se lensky está eh de alguna
manera pues con toda la energía para las
próximas semanas es ahí porque siempre
fue de alguna manera el objetivo
principal
profesor Vladimir rubís que Bienvenido a
Francia 24 y quiero hacerle la misma
pregunta Rusia ha alegado que los
ucranianos han cometido un genocidio en
la región del dumba así que por eso
intervinieron militarmente qué tan
cierta o falsa es esta afirmación
Bueno yo creo que lo primero que hay que
decir que el gobierno de Vladimir Putin
en mismísimo Vladimir Putin han cambiado
las cuentas las explicaciones las
narrativas Ya por lo menos unas docenas
de veces en cuanto a la explicación
porque Rusia inició la Guerra en Ucrania
en cuando la pregunta específica acerca
del genocidio no hay evidencias de
ningún genocidio cometido por los
ucranianos durante estos ocho años que
pasaron después de la revolución de
broma andan después del comienzo de los
combates de esta guerra interna en
Ucrania de hecho sabemos que hay una
investigación abierta que fue iniciada
por Ucrania misma Ucrania no tenía que
hacer caso a en algunas demandas decimos
de la Corte Internacional de la área
porque no hace parte del sistema
internacional en este aspecto pero
ucranio voluntariamente dijo bueno
vamos a ver si Rusia dice que hubo
genocidio por favor presentan las
evidencias que corresponden a la
definición que es genocidio y ahora hay
una investigación abierta pero todo
indica que no hubo que no sitio Entonces
es un pretexto absolutamente falso que
fue utilizado por Vladimir Putin para
justificar la guerra la ofensiva que
comenzó Rusia en febrero de este año y
si no hay genocidio entonces
Cuál es detrás de todo esto y recordemos
que Cuando comenzó la guerra el 24 de
febrero Rusia ya tenía el control de una
tercera parte del Don vas que está
compuesto por los obblast del lugar y
esto lo logró después de la guerra que
se desencadenó en 2014 tras la anexión
de crimea allí en el don Bass se produce
carbón y acero están las mayores plantas
ucranianas Cuál es la importancia de
esta región y porque Rusia entonces
tendría interés y le quiero preguntar
primero al profesor rubinsky
Bueno hay varios factores detrás de la
decisión de atacar a Ucrania detrás de
detención de transformar esta guerra
escondida que Rusia estaba participando
al lado de la repúblicas separatistas
durante todos estos años pero yo creo
que lo más importante aquí es la
cuestión simbólica para los rusos
Ucrania tiene un valor simbólico sin
precedente la narrativa Clara y central
de la respuesta a la pregunta de dónde
proviene Rusia está vinculado
íntimamente con la historia de Ucrania y
allá el hecho de que Ucrania es un país
separado es un país independiente
siempre a generar muchos inquietudes no
solamente en el mente en la cabeza de
Vladimir Putin sino también para muchos
rusos Será muy difícil aceptar esta
narrativa histórica Que hará diferente a
la tradicional rusa hay claramente hay
algunos intereses de algunos sectores
industriales allá pero hay que tener en
cuenta que si bien la parte de Don vaso
lugar donde está concentrado la
población étnicamente rusa Es solamente
una parte de la región el resto de la
región son las zonas Rurales con una
producción importante agrícola donde la
mayor parte de la población siempre ha
sido ucranianos entonces también desde
este punto de vista cuando están
hablando que los rusos que estamos
defendiendo las los territorios rusos
estamos defendiendo a los rusos es es
una noticia falsa porque antes de que
comienza la guerra en 2014 de hecho 60
por ciento de la población de toda la
región No únicamente de las ciudades
como botones pero de toda la región que
ahora Rusia pretende tomar el control y
por eso hay una pelea una guerra ahora
ya los combates pero el resto de
territorio no son los rusos sino
predominantemente son los ucranianos y
en efecto este interés que va más allá
de ese control cultural de los sectores
pero rusos Rusia Ha logrado crear un
corredor en el este y en el sur
ucraniano como lo veíamos en la nota
anterior y allí han logrado el control
de mariupol que es la ciudad más grande
bajo el gobierno de Moscú en este
momento y también veíamos en el informe
del mapa de cómo las tropas rusas han
avanzado y ahora controlan casi la
totalidad de lugares gran parte de
dunesk han controlado mariupol que era
el principal Puerto ucraniano al mar de
azov y se acercan cada vez más a odesa
que con lo que controlarían el acceso al
mar Negro si logran el control de Odessa
podrían acercarse a atrás nistria que es
esta región procesa en moldavia Le
quiero preguntar a la profesora chapa
geopolíticamente Qué significa el
control del este del sur ucraniano para
qué le sirve esto a Rusia
pues seguramente el control del este
puede implicar una futura anexión que
que reitero de alguna manera sí creo que
esa sea la intención detrás de todo esto
pero por otra parte el control marítimo
tiene mucho que ver con el
abastecimiento con las exportaciones con
controlar económicamente Ucrania no De
hecho hay cifras que dicen que Ucrania
exportaba
grano y y y aceite comestible como seis
millones de toneladas mensuales a través
del mar y hoy por hoy lo está pudiendo
hacer nada más una no de alguna manera
están bloqueando y las vías terrestres
Son complejas son más difíciles hay que
invertir mucho en volverlas a activar no
entonces este definitivamente bloquea
posibilidades militares a través del mar
Pero también las económicas no y también
el tema del Xbox de hecho se le está
acusando a Putin de de de utilizar el
hambre como arma de guerra precisamente
por todos los países que dependen de las
exportaciones que después segura a
profundizaremos en este tema no que
dependen de las exportaciones de grano y
aceite de Ucrania que no lo están
pudiendo hacer precisamente por eso y en
efecto como usted lo dice luego
profundizaremos en este tema y es una de
las preguntas que les tengo pero antes
de eso profesora chapa Le quiero
preguntar en este momento hay dos
ciudades que siguen en poder de los
ucranianos que son severonías y si estas
dos caen los rusos controlarían
totalmente el oblast de logansk se puede
acabar la guerra si Rusia logra
controlar el don vas como se lo proponía
originalmente o allí No termina todo
Hoy estamos en un punto muy complejo no
porque el nacionalismo ucraniano pues
obviamente se disparó y obviamente el
día de hoy las encuestas dicen que los
ucranianos están completamente en contra
de la sesión de terrenos y la sesión de
tierras no Entonces yo creo que ya
estamos en un punto de no hay vuelta
atrás fácil de no hay de no hay una este
salida sencilla
qué tanto se va a pelear Hasta qué tanto
se van a intentar recuperar Pues será
una cosa que tendrán que decidir como
naciones y sobre todo este políticamente
sea una decisión compleja pero pues
también de alguna manera Hay que
responder al electorado por parte densky
que se ha visto me parece no digo
imposible pero pero tal vez muy mucho
más complejo de lo que nos pudiera
parecer de que este se quedan con con
esa parte y se terminó la guerra porque
precisamente los la ciudadanía ucraniana
que ya invirtió
su su de alguna manera su paz Ya están
al estado en el ejército ya están
peleando ya están aburridísimos ya ya
tuvieron sufrieron muchísimos daños creo
que va a ser difícil soltarlo nada más
así y como usted Precisamente lo
mencionaba Estados Unidos y la
presidenta de la comisión de la Unión
Europea Úrsula bunderleyen acusan a
Rusia de utilizar el suministro de
alimentos como un arma occidente estado
denunciando que Moscú está tomando como
Rehenes y estas son palabras explícitas
la Casa Blanca a los alimentos en ese
sentido Le quiero preguntar al Señor
rubinsky Qué significa para Ucrania
perder el acceso al mar Negro y perder
el acceso al mar de azogue Qué significa
esto en términos de exportación de
granos y aceite
bueno significa obviamente mucho porque
no debemos olvidar que Ucrania es el
país más grande de este de Europa si
nosotros no estamos tomando en cuenta a
Rusia Ucrania siempre ha sido una granja
de Europa Ucrania ha sido un producto
importante de muchos el alimentos y
claramente sin tener acceso a las rutas
de distribución de estos elementos el
hecho incluso de tener Alimentos como
tal significa que no van a poder llegar
a los mercados y va a haber un déficit
ya está siendo
unos
evidencias que va a haber un déficit en
algunos de los sectores muy importantes
del sector agrícola en algunos de tipos
de alimentos y claramente pues esto es
Es una herramienta de presión que puedo
utilizar el gobierno de Vladimir Putin y
sin embargo yo creo que
todo indica ahora que hay menos
incentivos por ambos partos e incluso
para poder llegar a alguna negociación
ya no hay vuelta a lo normal de tres
guerras ya las acciones de el gobierno
de Vladimir de la Rusia de puchen a
poner Un fin en cualquier Esperanza que
se puede llegar a
regresar al Punto de partida en febrero
cuando Rusia atacó Ucrania Entonces yo
creo que en este contexto seguramente
van a ver los problemas que son
difícilmente solucionables pero también
no debemos tomar como por acertado que
la situación en el frente de la guerra
va a seguir como sigue o sea nosotros
vemos unos avances de los rusos y luego
tenían que retroceder a los ucranianos
ahora sienten muchísimo más seguros en
sus capacidades de combate Entonces el
control quiero Rusia ahora tú tiene No
necesariamente va a poder a mantener
a largo plazo Aunque eso es seguramente
es una de las metas de Rusia está
hablando de la perspectiva de militar y
la crisis no solo se vive en los
suministros de alimentos porque los
precios de petróleo y gas sean disparado
en todo el mundo y es que Rusia es uno
de los mayores proveedores de este
insumo especialmente para la Unión
Europea que depende en un 60% de los
combustibles fósiles que se producen en
Rusia Le quiero preguntar en ese sentido
a la profesora chapa que implica la
guerra en este sentido para el petróleo
y para el gas y cuánto está sufriendo el
mundo por la gran Ucrania en estos
aspectos
seguramente una alza de precios ahorita
inmediatamente a corto plazo también una
reconfiguración de entendiendo ahorita
que el invierno va de de salida Entonces
el tema estacional está ayudando un poco
no Y una reconfiguración de de de
suministro de de de dónde de dónde
obtener hidrocarburos deben de obtener
gases y y como vemos unos acercamientos
a países de América Latina por ejemplo
estamos viendo este como este Los lazos
con Venezuela poco a poco Estados Unidos
los está suavizando para ver si eso
pudiera ser porque Probablemente sí se
vaya a cumplir el veto al al petróleo
igual o El crudo o al crudo este Ruso y
de alguna manera estamos viendo a
ahorita por ejemplo Polonia vulgar y
Grecia que fueron los que más sufrieron
este el tema del gas eh desde el
suministro del gas ruso ya están
encontrando de alguna manera a través de
lo que ya existe no en azerbaiyán
Alemania no el el el el el suministro
para el día de hoy a largo plazo va a
implicar mucha reconfiguración y va a
implicar este que que se busquen de otra
manera Y de alguna manera un empuje a
los a los renovables no que que que
Europa ya estaba haciendo un un esfuerzo
muy grande en ese sentido y a pesar de
que esta sanción de vetar el petróleo
ruso Todavía no se ha concretado en la
Unión Europea si ha habido múltiples
sanciones económicas de occidente en
contra de Moscú y en contra del círculo
cercano del kremlin a pesar de esto
Vladimir Putin ha sostenido que ellos no
son los más afectados sino que los más
afectados serán los mismos países de
occidente y en ese sentido el Ministerio
de desarrollo de economía Rusia ha dicho
que el pib ruso va a caer entre un 8 y
un 10% este año mientras que las
estimaciones del Banco Mundial hablan de
una caída del 45% del pib ucraniano en
ese sentido quién está perdiendo más en
la guerra en términos económicos Ucrania
o Rusia y le preguntó al profesor
rubinsky
yo no tengo duda como responder a esta
pregunta El perdedor es Rusia Lo que
pasa que ahora el impacto de las
sanciones no se siente porque no se
trata de un impacto inmediato pero a
Rusia efectivamente está excluida de una
buena parte de los mercados
internacionales las empresas que tenían
en diversión en Rusia las empresas
extranjeras están saliendo Y estos
narrativas rusas que nosotros vamos a
crear nuestros propios aviones en un año
que nosotros vamos a tener nuestras
mejores carros de todos los tiempos Es
simplemente una bravada es una es es no
es real Entonces yo creo que lo que va a
hacer el colapso que va a tener Rusia es
está por venir es muy probable que las
primeras
evidencias del colapso que va a sentir
la población rusa aún más porque ahora
es más temores más miedo que a la
población rusa pero pero va a sentir por
allá a los finales del año o
posiblemente en la segunda mitad del año
para decir algo
bloomberg que en estos 10 publicó que
los aviones que tiene Rusia los aviones
porque tiene un porcentaje muy pequeño
de sus propios aviones tiene partes para
tres meses y después de tres meses
realmente va a ser una lotería para
subir a ese avión y volar entonces en
todo lo que tiene que la inversión que
tiene que ver con la innovación Rusia no
tiene acceso esto Esto es una vuelta a
la década 90 o la década 80 Rusia no es
la unión soviética Rusia tiene muy pocos
propios oportunidades para poder
realmente reemplazar lo que lo que tiene
que ver con las acciones la salida de
las empresas el acceso al mundo Mira el
rublo efectivamente dejó ser una moneda
libremente convertible tiene una tasa de
cambio más o menos artificial 58 rublos
que los medios rusos dice Ay mira qué
tan estable que rubro es tan fuerte No
es porque no hay no es una moneda que
realmente se puede comparar y vender
fácil Entonces el impacto es para Rusia
el docente Vladimir nos dice Rusia es El
perdedor económico de la guerra y le
quiero hacer la misma pregunta a la
profesora Marcela usted quién cree que
pierde más en esta guerra seguramente el
tema del crecimiento de las tasas de
crecimiento y tal pues se ven afectadas
porque la guerra se está peleando en
Ucrania no y físicamente la
infraestructura de Ucrania está muy
dañada no Pero de alguna manera este el
el hecho de que Ucrania siga con su
economía conectada este a a la Unión
Europea y que siga teniendo apoyo de
occidente y lo seguirá teniendo y y
ahora hasta con un gesto de solidaridad
puede ser importante en el tema de la
recuperación después de que esto termine
entonces la infraestructura seguramente
en
donde más ha sufrido y donde seguirá
sufriendo no pero pero justamente
coincido completamente con el profesor
robbinsky de alguna manera este el el a
largo plazo
la economía eucariana probablemente vaya
a tener que recuperar el el el tema de
la infraestructura y poco más de alguna
manera Los lazos económicos seguirán
estando ahí la voluntad de de la
ciudadanía ucraniana para levantar su
nación seguramente estará con muchísima
más fuerza y y y con Rusia veremos hay
gente que es escéptica de de de las de
lo que lo que puede pasar a través de la
sanciones pero seguramente No no como
decíamos no va a haber un vuelta atrás A
como estaba antes de la guerra
seguramente pierden todos perdemos todos
pero de Cara a largo plazo Ucrania tiene
menos que perder Sí y ahora quiero que
pasemos a analizar el panorama político
Cuáles han sido las consecuencias en
estos tres meses de conflicto en
múltiples el consejo de seguridad de la
ONU ha intentado aprobar resoluciones
que han sido tumbadas por el veto de
Rusia en contra de la guerra en Ucrania
y la guerra ha continuado Mi pregunta es
por qué los organismos internacionales
no han podido frenar los combates le
pregunta a usted profesor
desde mi punto de vista viviríamos en un
momento de la transición la invasión
rusa
hizo evidente que las reglas de juego
anteriormente aceptados por la mayoría
de los actores en la arena internacional
ya se vuelvan obsoletos hay unas grietas
fuertes en la arquitectura del sistema
internacional
y que básicamente muchos de estos
arreglos de juego los fundamentos del
sistema internacional
reflejaron las realidades que existían
en el mundo después de el fin de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial y una de las
razones porque los organismos
internacionales no son capaces de hacer
algo más allá de lo que están haciendo
porque no podemos decir que no están
haciendo absolutamente nada sí por lo
menos hacen por ejemplo un trabajo
importante para tener los hechos
registrados relacionados con la guerra
pero una de las razones por ejemplo en
las Naciones Unidas Rusia escenadora de
el puesto del Consejo permanente de las
Naciones Unidas y básicamente tiene su
derecho abierto y no dudó abusar ese
derecho abierto entonces bloquea
efectivamente cualquier decisión que
puede salir desde las Naciones Unidas y
yo creo que básicamente en adelante
podemos ver como como va desarrollandose
realmente la situación pero yo veo muy
difícil que los organismos
internacionales pueden jugar un papel
decisivo en cuando la tarea de acabar
con la guerra de parar lo que hacen los
rusos yo veo realmente muy pocos
oportunidades que ellos pueden realmente
tener algo en ese sentido uno de esos
organismos internacionales que ha
intentado intervenir es la otan la
alianza militar de los países del
Atlántico norte Sin embargo ellos solo
pueden operar en los países miembro y
Ucrania no es uno de ellos a pesar de
esto
dice que la otan no puede expandirse y
acercarse a sus fronteras y parte de
esto era su argumento de la Guerra sin
embargo hizo todo lo contrario Pues
impulsó a Finlandia y a Suecia que
históricamente habían sido países
neutrales a solicitar la membresía a la
alianza militar profesora chapa se puede
leer esto como que fracasó el intento de
Putin de alejar militarmente occidente
yo creo que
se despertó el dragón dormido que se
despertó también el el el lo que parecía
de anacrónico de la guerra como la
conocemos la guerra frontal tal
superadísima pues de alguna manera nos
hace ver que no es real y que los y que
los organismos de cooperación militar
son importantes son necesarios la Unión
Europea intentó patear el tema y lo
intentó patear y se veía la necesidad
pero no se tomaban acciones concretas
para eso está lo tanto Está media
dormida no entonces en todo en todo este
en todo este discurso de alguna manera
se despierta la necesidad de de también
tener alianzas militares efectivas que
sí que sí funcionen Y entonces a lo
mejor el tema de la frontera ucraniana
que es la que le preocupaba a Rusia este
no se terminará de definir Próximamente
Y probablemente si usted hace un paso
demasiado fuerte o demasiado este
agresivo si pueda tener una reacción
grande pero seguramente despertó
seguramente recalcó la importancia y
vemos el tema de Finlandia y Suecia no
que el que se están cuestionando este su
su neutralidad o su no pertenencia al
organismo por tantos años no Pero porque
precisamente
se están dando cuenta que que este tema
que parecía ya superado en la política
internacional lamentablemente no lo está
el tema nuclear sigue vivo y y y y el
tema de las fronteras que parecían ya
sacrosantas y que existían todos estos
mecanismos de guerra Proxy y de apoyar a
otros todavía existían pero este frontal
no y y se ha revivido no y quiero
utilizar la semejanza que usted hace se
despertó el dragón dormido para hablar
en términos militares y yo también me
atrevería a decir que se despertó el
dragón dormido en las relaciones
diplomáticas porque Rusia se ha acercado
o se ha intentado acercar cada vez más a
China profesor rubinski Hay una
posibilidad de una alianza entre estos
dos países y qué significaría para
Occidente
Bueno yo diría yo no utilizaría la
palabra la alianza Rusia lo que hizo
ahora el resultado el fracaso realmente
con el lazo objetivo porque puse no ha
logrado de militarizar Ucrania no
logrado cambiar el gobierno de Ucrania
lo que hizo en el cuando a la otan es
todo al contrario Porque otan está
creciendo así es un dragón realmente que
está ya muy consciente de su fuerza de
la necesidad que tiene los europeos para
mantener este dragón alimentado con los
recursos con las armamentos lo único que
va a quedar habladimir Es realmente
acercarse a China Pero cuál es el
problema para Rusia las condiciones para
esta asociación no va a defender Rusia
las
reglas de juego de esta nueva
convivencia entre Rusia Ucrania va a
definir china entonces Putin ya la Rusia
de Putin está vendiendo petróleo y gasa
china con los precios muy por debajo de
los precios que están maneja en el
mercado internacional china va a
aprovechar por lo máximo el fracaso de
la estrategia de Vladimir puchen y por
eso yo estoy diciendo que posiblemente
no debemos hablar de una alianza sino
Debemos hablar de una asociación donde
Rusia va a jugar el papel del socio
menor y donde china va a ser mucho más
fuerte Precisamente en eurasia por esta
guerra en Ucrania y esto significa mucho
para occidente obviamente porque ahora
va a enfrentar china aún más
fortaleciéndose y que tiene que
realmente enfrentar las nuevas
realidades desde la perspectiva
geopolítica y geoestratégica un
reacomodamiento geopolítico Entonces es
lo que nos dejará la guerra en Ucrania
creciendo más a China según el análisis
de nuestros invitados quiero hacerles
una pregunta que no quiero dejar escapar
y es en Ucrania ya se realizó el primer
juicio de guerra desde que comenzó la
invasión rusa del 24 de febrero y el
sargento ruso
21 años fue condenado a cadena perpetua
por asesinar a un civil que estaba
desarmado y esto se realizó este juicio
se realizó Precisamente en Ucrania
profesora chapa se está repitiendo el
modelo de los juicios de nuremberg en la
que los aliados juzgaron a los nazis que
combatieron
no sé si si si en ese momento si si se
puede hacer un paragón directo y sobre
todo porque ahorita lo estamos viendo
mientras la guerra continúa
pero seguramente Sí sí es
Pues un llamado y y una no sé cómo que
para utilizar pero de decir si vamos a
invertir justicia y sí lo vamos a hacer
ya este y ya están intentando también
cambiar hacer un intercambio de
prisioneros no porque para para que para
que para que el tema no porque creo que
sí sí es esta
como llamado a la valentía decir no
podemos permitir que sigan existiendo
crímenes de guerra ahorita y a pesar de
que todo mundo en el contexto
internacional está de acuerdo en que eso
se juzga después si son muchos años y es
un proceso larguísimo pero decir no
podemos permitir que se maten civiles
hoy aunque sea simbólico Aunque no vaya
a tener mucha mucha repercusión no pero
pero pero sí decir estamos haciendo algo
y no estamos jugando el juego de la
guerra como como como como como este de
alguna manera nos tuvimos obligados a
jugar el juego de la guerra aunque no
hubiéramos querido y tampoco queremos
que los civiles sufren por ahí Creo que
sería lo que lo que yo veo y si no
queremos que lo sufí que los civiles
sufran precisamente eso nos da pie para
hablar del impacto humanitario que ha
tenido la guerra y que en cifras de la
ONU es bastante pues más de 3.900
civiles han muerto según la oficina del
alto comisionado de la ONU para los
Derechos Humanos
6,5 millones de personas que vivían en
Ucrania se refugiaron en otros países y
más de 8 millones de personas se
desplazaron dentro de la Ucrania en ese
sentido Le quiero preguntar profesor
rubinsky Sabiendo el impacto humanitario
Por qué es tan difícil juzgar los
crímenes Y por qué hasta ahora solo
tenemos un caso que es el del Sargento
ruso que acabamos de mencionar
Bueno una de las razones mi Colega ya
estaba mencionando que para poder
organizar un proceso que puede ser
parecido a lo que hicieron en núremberg
que necesitamos que las potencias de la
arena internacional están de acuerdo
porque debe ser un juicio internacional
y Rusia no hace parte de la mayor parte
de los organismos que están suscritos
con la corte en la área No hay forma de
poder hacer este juicio en este momento
y sin embargo es absolutamente necesario
en primer lugar hacer un registro de los
hechos Sí porque las cosas luego pasan y
y uno ya no tiene acceso a este material
probatorio Entonces yo lo que veo ahora
es muy importante que sí efectivamente
están recolectando esta información
están realmente haciendo un registro de
los crímenes de la guerra y lo que
hicieron por ejemplo en Ucrania es
utilizar el Sistema Nacional ucraniano
porque están previstos en el código
penal hay previstos estos crímenes si
realmente realizar los juicios con las
herramientas que están disponibles en
este momento y para ir cerrando nuestro
debate Quiero preguntarle a nuestros
invitados quizás la pregunta más difícil
de responder empezando con usted
profesor rubinsky que se necesita para
que se acabe la guerra en Ucrania
se necesita que realmente a Rusia ya no
tiene recursos para continuar la guerra
que tiene que llegar un momento cuando
debe estar muy claro que la continuación
de la guerra no tiene absolutamente
ningún sentido han cometido un montón de
errores No han logrado tener los
objetivos cumplidos y yo creo que es
debe ser una cuestión de simplemente de
tiempo cuando la guerra debe terminar
profesora Marcela chapa le hago la misma
pregunta a usted quien está en México
Qué se necesita para que se acabe la
guerra en Ucrania
Ojalá pudiéramos saber no de alguna
manera esta guerra nos ha nos ha
sorprendido a muchos con con con
precisamente con categorías que que
creíamos superadas no como como ya
habíamos comentado anteriormente
Probablemente sí probablemente La
Apuesta tenga que ser por el desgaste
tenga que ser por porque Rusia Por más
que maneja esta narrativa de grandeza
militar todavía sabemos que tiene
eficiencia sabemos este que
económicamente no está bien parado como
como como nos hacen ver entonces Este sí
creo que que la estrategia del desgaste
que que seguramente una de las cosas que
se leens que ha hecho es hacer que en
estos meses que no se pierda el tema de
la agenda no que no pierda vigencia que
la gente no es que ya ya pasó la guerra
y ya ya pierda de alguna manera el el
fervor de Cara a la opinión pública y
sobre todo la opinión pública en
occidente que es la que la que de alguna
manera va a proveer el apoyo militar y
económico a Ucrania no Entonces es una
de las cosas que he intentado como
mantener vivas para que para que para
que pues después de es un poco salió de
los titulares de todos los días que que
pasó al principio no entonces una de las
cosas que ha hecho celenski Precisamente
en esta en esta pues apuesta por por el
desgaste y por el tiempo que también nos
va a desgastar a ellos seguramente y que
también va a tener este pues pues eh
repercusiones negativas en todos los
aspectos pero probablemente sea el
camino bueno ya miraremos entonces cómo
terminará la guerra en Ucrania y si esta
estrategia del desgaste es lo que va a
llevar al final de ella o si como lo
decía el profesor rubinsky será la falta
de suministros Al fin y al cabo en
términos militares de todas maneras
geopolíticamente hay un reacomodamiento
de las fuerzas con China la otan la
Unión Europea y Estados Unidos en el
medio Yo Le Quiero agradecer a nuestros
invitados Marcela chapa y Vladimir
rubinsky por estar aquí con nosotros en
France 24 en el debate
al contrario un placer Muchas gracias
y a ustedes los invitamos a que sigan
conectados con toda la programación de
France 24 pueden encontrar el debate en
nuestra página web France 24.com y
también en nuestro canal de YouTube nos
vemos en una próxima ocasión
[Música]